hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast prediction of
enzalutamide sensitivity in triple
negative breast cancer presented by dr.
joel parker i'm susie valdez of lab
roots and i will be your moderator for
today's event today's presentation is
sponsored by nano stream technologies
nana string technologies is a publicly
held provider of life science tools for
translational research and molecular
diagnostics the company's technology
enables a wide variety of basic research
translational medicine and in vitro
diagnostics application nana streams
products are based on a novel digital
molecular barcoding technology invented
at the institute of systems biology in
seattle under the direction of dr. leroy
hood we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
elaborate the leading scientific social
network website provider of virtual
events and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone this
presentation is interactive we want to
hear from you the questions comments and
even answers can be submitted via the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your screen will try to get to everyone
but if not we will make sure to follow
up with you by e-mail you can enlarge
the slide window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of your slide window if you
cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on a
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button at your lower left this is an
educational webinar and best offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the c/e
button located at the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I would
now like to introduce today's speaker
dr. joel parker dr. Parker's research is
focused on the methodological
development and integrated analysis of
high-throughput genetic and genomic
studies he previously led the
development of other
and cut content resulting in pro stigma
TM and only Cee marked and the fda 510 k
cleared breast cancer diagnostic assay
for ffpe tissue he is currently involved
in similar diagnostic development in
kidney and bladder cancer and recently
presented a novel predictive biomarker
for the insula to demise in triple
negative breast cancer which is being
used as entry criteria for a phase 3
trial dr. Parker currently directs the
sequencing microarray and other genomic
analysis in the bioinformatics shared
resource at the Lineberger Comprehensive
Cancer Center the impact of his
collaborative effort are demonstrated in
publications which are presently
constituted over a hundred and fifty
peer-reviewed publications all I can now
turn over the presentation to dr. Parker
welcome sir thank you very much and
thanks for that nice introduction so
today I'll get to talk about in
flutamide in our development of this
biomarker I did this work in in with
company called Medivation he produces
expand it was also going by include
ahmad this is in in collaboration with
Katrina Kerry and heard st paul so in
lieu de mod is a potent inhibitor at AR
signaling androgen receptor is one of
the key components in prostate cancer
and is used and this drug is used in
metastatic castration-resistant prostate
cancer or it gives a significant benefit
and overall survival in this particular
study we wanted to see look at its
activity in breast cancer but what is
known is that it actually inhibits AR
signaling in multiple different ways
inhibits binding of antigens to AR it
inhibits the nuclear look translocation
and also inhibits androgen mediated DNA
binding so in this phase 2 study of
enzalutamide here in triple negative
breast cancer women were recruited if
they were androgen receptor positive but
meaning that they had some staining
of androgen receptor by um you know mr.
chemistry and that was basically any
staining so it's a very sensitive assay
and they had to have advanced triple
negative breast cancer and triple
negative being defined a lack of
abstaining for estrogen receptor for her
to or progesterone receptor they could
have any number of prior therapies and
owned and out for bone only disease but
no brain metastases were allowed also
these patients were when as a tissue was
taken for for genomics as you'll see in
just a minute the primary endpoint of
the study was clinical benefit rate at
16 weeks which was had to be used due to
the due to the aggressiveness of these
metastatic triple negative breast
cancers we also collected other end
points such as 24-week clinical benefit
progression-free survival and overall
survival which i'll present today this
was a single armoire Simon's design
study where in stage one we had to see
at least three of 26 evaluable patients
have a clinical benefit of 16 weeks and
if so it progressed to stage two which
the study did and in that in that subset
seek raising a toe or a total of greater
than nine out of 62 patients to
constitute rejection of null hypothesis
that there is clear benefit of a tree
interceptor so the interesting thing
about this drug in this study is that
the triple negative breast cancer is
typically treated with cytotoxic
chemotherapy and cytotoxic chemotherapy
is we all know had as many many very bad
side effects in contrast this drug
include amide has a very very
conservative safety profile in that it
only has grade three adverse effects of
fatigue in a very low percentage of
patients so it is much provides a much
better quality of life for the patient
and in this study the this was single
agent so these women received no
cytotoxic chemotherapy they only receive
this hormone therapy as part of the
study one of the one of the initial
hopes was that IHC would be able to
understand it would be able to for us to
evaluate and identify those women that
would benefit from the drug as androgen
receptor the drug target can be easily
stained for what we see in these plots
first on the left and the
intent-to-treat population is that
staining at a threshold of greater than
ten percent produces some but still
modest benefit with progression-free
survival extending from eight weeks to
fourteen and a half weeks of fifty
percent or meet fifty percent survival
if you reduce the population to just
those women who received zero or one
prior therapy so they weren't extent
extensively treated prior to entering
the study that benefit had increased
with fifty percent surviving at eight
and a half weeks for less when they had
less than ten percent AR staining and
seventeen point six weeks for those it
had greater than or equal to ten percent
they are staining however this was not
statistically significant and the the
samples were used further for biomarker
analysis so this slide demonstrates the
kind of comprehensive set of biomarkers
that were assayed as part of the study
RNA sequencing was used for whole
transcript for two sav whole
transcriptome this was using a ribose
ero technique to remove all the
ribosomal material and then sequence
total RNA after that this led to the
evaluation by pam 50 a classification
technique commercialized as the pro
sigma diagnostic which provides
information about individual subtypes of
breast cancer and is indicated for
producing risk of recurrent scores other
classification procedures that we
investigated include the layman
classification which is specific for
triple negative breast cancers and
notably includes an androgen receptor up
high subgroup or andrew
inter sensitive subtype potentially and
then we also use this to mine for novel
signatures of androgen receptor gene
sensitivity or drug sensitivity and then
there was also DNA available and this
DNA was was utilized in order to look
for mutations that might be it might be
useful in determining those patients who
are likely to be sensitive to the drug
now in all these cases development has
to occur however the amount of
development to get through to a
successful test vary in debt with things
like the fam 50 classification because
it's already commercialized that it's
possible that simply using those using
those same sub classes or subtypes that
are defined by the time 50 if they are
predictive would allow for a very rapid
translation to the clinic in contrast
other these other biomarkers or
candidate biomarkers would have to go
through extensive development in order
to see the light of day as a clinical as
a clinically useful classifier prior to
prior to going deep into biomarker
development we first wanted to
understand whether there were there
associations with response what we're
looking at here is a heat map of
indicating the gene expression of a few
hundred genes 521 genes that were
significantly associated with included
matter spots the color bar on the top
indicates those that are a are positive
by G in the black and then those in gray
at that top color borrower or a Ric
negative and thus were not part of the
intent-to-treat population the second
color bar shows the Pam 50 subtype and
I'll just point out that red in that
color bar is the basal like subtype
while other colors represent various
luminal subtypes luminal a B her too and
the normal like the third row shows blue
and gray we're gray represents those
patients that did not achieve 16-week
clinical benefit and blue are those that
had a response or head clinical benefit
at 16 weeks when clustering over this
this set of genes where red indicates
high expression and green indicates
relatively lower expression we see a
cluster we see a cluster on the Left
marker up that shows that shows very
high expression of a set of genes
including the androgen receptor this
this particular cluster is also enriched
with responders shown in blue and is
typically non basal light by the Pam 50
subclass on the right hand side we see
the group of samples that are that are
almost one hundred percent basal-like
and there are very few responders in
this group as noted by almost no blue in
the gray versus blue color bar and a
very different gene expression profile
with the majority of genes being highly
expressed as a majority of these 521
genes being highly expressed in that
basil like for group when we did
enrichment analysis for these two groups
of genes that is those high in the in
the non basil group and that it been
risk that are responsive and those high
in the basal light group that don't
typically respond we find biological
meaning in that we find breast cancer
subtypes being enriched in both of these
classes notably that the ones on the
right being basal-like and those emotes
are left high on the left side of the
heat map of being more luminal like we
also find signatures of a cochrane
response from a paper by former at all
that I'll get to you in a moment and
also I don't know if this is listed here
but we also saw signatures of androgen
receptor activity from cell line based
models when we limit this analysis down
to just those that are basil like to try
to produce the most homogeneous
population that we can we removed many
of the responsive cases in fact only
only six or seven responders show up
within this group of basil light cases
when we test within this bait within
this group of only basil likes what we
see is a similar expression profile
showing that even those that are called
basil like but do respond have signals
that are that are relevant to to
basically non basil or more luminal life
and that's shown by the gene sets that
pop up in the non responder patients
that's these patients here in blue
showing targets like a differentiation
which is typically with this particular
gene set goes along with proliferation
and others and then a mr. next slide we
dig a little bit more deeply into the
Pam 50 measures and we're looking here
at the distance instead of just calling
them specific subtypes of basil versus
liminal we're looking at individual
subtypes or the quantitative measure of
these individual subtypes in order to
see how strong these different measures
are and what we find is that the
distance to basil shown in the bots in
the box plots in the top left strongly
segregates responders from
non-responders with those patients that
have to have their very close to very
similar to basil likes being
non-responders and those that are more
distant having a negative correlation
being to say that properly those that
are more similar to Basil's having a
strong positive correlation being
non-responders and those that are far
from Basil's or having a large negative
correlation being responders while her
two measures to the left or to the right
that don't show much difference and then
luminal a measures show the contrast of
the Basil's with those that are being
more different than luminal A's being
nonresponders and those being more
similar to Linda late showing larger
positive correlation typically being
responsive and when we we just plot
these two measures against each other
basically the correlations to luminal a
versus the correlation to basil in a
scatter plot on the far right you see
that these two measures are strongly
correlated with a negative direction and
and what we find is that if when we
color by non
Fondor vs responder it does those
patients that are typically stronger
correlates to luminal a and negatively
correlated with basil are enriched in
the responders and this is the signal
that will continue to exploit as we
develop our biomarker but before we
before we look further at the Pam 50
calls we wanted to spend some time with
the ape recurrent subtype this subtype
was first described by farmer at all in
oncogene paper in 2000 involved in this
paper they they looked across a number
of different public data sets listed
here and shows it in every one of them
there is a small but definitely present
a set of patients which display this a
Kirk Ron or or antigen receptor driven
like phenotype so we wanted to develop a
predictor of this particular phenotype
and using the former data set which is
shown on the right we try to look for a
set of genes that would be predictive of
this apron subtype in the heat map on
the right the basal the Basil's are
colored with red and the color bar at
the top those that were a pecans from
the paper were colored in purple and
those that were luminal or colored blue
we used a simple we use a simple linear
modeling based strategy in order to
determine a set of genes that were
predictive of these three classes and
what's shown on the left is the accuracy
of that classifier across cross
validation test sets relative to the
number of genes that were used in the
model and so in the end we use 200 about
200 genes which produced around a
ninety-four percent accuracy in those
jeans are shown in that heat map on the
right and at this level we could produce
a classifier that we could take over to
our study cohort and predict apricot
subtype and understand if that
particular subtype as those predictions
were associated with response so here's
that results on the left or the 200
genes from the visualized in
the meditation cohort or the involute
ahmad study the top color bar is showing
predictions based on the models built
from the former at all data the
predictions in purple are the ape ekron
the blues or liminal and red predictions
are Basil's in the second color board
the the gray and blue again the gray or
nonresponders and the blue are
responders what we see is that the the
luminal employs a pro crimes in purple
are enriched for those blue or
responsive samples whereas the Basil's
on the right-hand side of a much lower
number of responders and and this is
matches the general features that we see
when looking at the pam fifty genes as
well now if we take this a pro cron
prediction to be our biomarker we can
see in the table in the middle that they
that of the a pro cron predictions about
fifty percent of them 12 out of 20 for
our responders however in the basil and
the luminal groups while the responders
are at a much lower frequency or much
lower proportioning the actual numbers
are still you know well above zero so
that if we took this predictor to be our
biomarker we would miss many of the
positive cases or many of the responsive
cases despite showing certainly accuracy
that's well above chance as you can see
through the sensitivity and specificity
curves at the top right or the ROC curve
on the bottom right another technique
that's out there for classifying triple
negative breast cancer alluded to
earlier was from this layman paper this
was in JC I back in 2011 and in this
paper they nicely demonstrate that
subtypes of triple negative breast
cancer can be reproducibly identified
they divided triple negative breast
cancer into basil into two different
basil white categories an immune
immunomodulatory group I'm as income
elitegroup I'm as income all stem
cell-like group and the luminal a our
group which we are most interested in
you
so this was done based on a larger panel
of 30 247 genes and our supposed subtype
classifications using laymen were
produced using the tool that is
described in that paper so here we can
choose two different strategies for
biomarker development the diagnostic
positive cases could simply be those
that are luminal they are however as
I'll show you in a second it would be
much more productive in order to just
describe diagnostic positive cases as
those that are not the basal one or
basal like two groups and that's shown
here is a bar plot so what we see on the
left-hand side or the basal like one
invader like two categories and blue is
showing the number of nonresponders with
the green bar stacked on top of those
responders so in our diagnostic negative
or basal like classes we get a we get
very large enrichment for non-responders
as we saw with the fam 50 or the AP
crime or the former that is based based
prediction strategies the innards are
not a diagnostic positive subgroups we
see that there is enrichment general
enrichment of responders and it's
especially true in the luminal a our
group which points to this subtype
generating the correct biology or
biological association for this group
because they have the largest enrichment
of responders to the drug however the
high level of non-responders in this
diagnostic positive population produces
a low positive predictive value that is
many samples that would be considered
positive we would not respond to the
drug now we could play with this and get
rid of the mesenchymal group which has
not moved those over to the negative
category to the vet that is the basal
light category and there's other things
we can do here but in the end if no good
strategy was able to to clearly
segregate diagnostic positive from
negative as you can see by this by the
way the bars are stuck in here
so in our last attempt using known
strategies this is the Pam 50 based
classification technique that I was
discussed a little bit earlier the 50
genes are shown on the left in a heat
map which demonstrates the profiles of
the four tumor types of interest luminal
a luminal B her to enriched invade the
light and what the way these an
individual sample was classified as
shown in the middle and that a single
sample which is unknown is taken and and
compared to each one of the individual
profiles and it is a sign the class of
the profile that is most similar so this
would be a sign profile a here likely
which which would look more like the
luminal a category and in this case we
would take diagnostic negative 2b
basal-like in diagnostic positives to be
all those non-fatal categories similar
as we did with layman as with the layman
classifier in this case the Pam 50
subtyping shows an enrichment of
responders in the diagnostic positive
category however there are plenty of
responders in that diagnostic negative
or basal light category and so in so
while this would work in enriching for
those that are positive it would miss
many many patients who would respond to
the drug which is which is also you know
a trade-off that we weren't quite
willing to make at this level of the
analysis so we continued further and
look to look more in depth at positive
predictive value sensitivity specificity
and negative predictive value of the
different classification schemes here on
the left is just revisiting the layman
based game versus the Pam 50 base scheme
on the right and just contrasting the
high level of non-responders and
diagnostic positives for laymen versus
the hollows of responders in the
diagnostic negative population for Pam
50 so this motivated us to go through a
model development exercise as part of
this exercise we use the number of
different feature set which included at
which is represented by each of the
curve in these two charts on the left so
what's shown is our clinical measures
reported out as clinical V or V these
are different IHC based classifications
using different antibodies and each one
of these clinical variables actually
incorporates 12 different measurements
of ihe including things like for
everything from total counts to nuclear
counts sources phytoplasma counts and
the ratios and what time we also
included Pam 50 based variables which
are the discrete subtype calls as well
as the distances or correlation state
centroid as I showed you earlier and we
included these features individually or
combined as well as different weighting
schemes of the 50 genes that were is Pam
50 the apron based predictor which is
shown by the green curve and then all of
these features together in a single
model which is the orange curve these
were all modeled using a Monte Carlo
cross-validation approach such that
two-thirds of the training set was taken
out a model was built and then
predicting that model was evaluated in
the third that were they were held out
as the test set that entire procedure
was repeated 500 times and in this prior
to that entire exercise of validations
that was set to the side which will come
back to as part of this process we
wanted to see what feature said as well
as what number of predictors in that
features that gave us the best overall
accuracy and on the top left you see
that many of these curves look very
similar so the general performance of
any of these feature sets was quite
similar and that's a good thing they're
all honing in on the same biology on the
bottom left you can see that if you have
to pick a winner that based on this
Monte Carlo cross-validation analysis
the light blue curve with this view is
one there possibly two features and that
is the Pam 50 bass scores gives us the
best general area under the curve so to
visualize that that one model another
way on the right now named the predict
AR biomarker the resistance based
predictions show
huge enrichment of nonresponders whereas
those that are predicted to be sensitive
to drug have a relative enrichment in
the responders shown in blue sensitivity
specificity positive predictive value
and negative predictive value of those
of this dog walker is shown at the top
from and this is estimated from the
Monte Carlo cross validation test sets
importantly the positive predictive
value is 45% meaning that 45% the
patient's predicted to be sensitive of
the drug will actually be while ninety
percent of those patients in the NPV
case that are not predicted to be
sensitive would not benefit from the
drug and this is in contrast to IHC
estimated where we've estimated these
measures the same way and just to close
the book on I see in this particular
biomarker case we see a ten-percent drop
in PPV and a similar drop in mtv showing
clear improvement of the predict a our
signature relative die HC so at this
point we have we've developed a
diagnostic assay for enzalutamide in
triple negative breast cancer the
patient's primary tumor or SSP sample is
run through this next-generation
sequencing assay 50 genes are extracted
these are the pam vista genes we measure
the distance to each of the centroids
are in each of the subtypes and using
the distance primarily the luminal a and
then secondarily to basal like these two
measures are combined to form our model
of include Ahmad sensitivity evaluating
the the data in different ways now from
the same cohort we look at first
waterfall plot of time on study and what
you see on the left or the predict they
are negative patients which generally
have shorter times on study and with
only a couple of patients which are
still active indicated by the orange
arrows on the positive predict they are
positive cases you can see that many
many patients are still on studies still
active on study taking the drug as well
as in general of the duration
the duration on study was much longer if
we look at progression-free survival
again the the model was not trained on
progression-free survival it was trained
on the 16-week clinical benefit and what
we see is that in the intensive tree
population that our median
progression-free survival is improved
from eight weeks to 16.1 weeks for the
entire population and if we limit to
just those where they're getting this
hormone therapy instead of cytotoxic
chemotherapy as their first as a first
or second line of therapy after disease
progression the median survival goes
from eight point nine weeks to forty
point four weeks so this is a tremendous
increase in in progression-free survival
for these patients in a multivariate
analysis utilizing both the predict a
our model as well as age and I see we
see again that the predict a our model
provides a significant predictive value
with the hazard ratio around point 45
second only to number of prior therapies
with zero one prior therapies being
beneficial in this cohort and this
effect carried through the overall
survival so what we what we're looking
at here is overall survival from the
cohort of the broken again by predict a
our status with predict ar- patients
sort of fifty percent of them surviving
out to 32 weeks and while the predict a
are positive patients surviving out to
seventy five weeks likely with a much
better quality of life in addition to
this improved survival time due to the
nature of the drug now it's possible
that this because that we know that the
model is weighted towards being luminal
zor at least not Basil's and those
patients will do better in the absence
of any drug we wanted to make sure that
this that this particular signature was
not simply prognostic but
it was predictive because it's was a
single arm trial with no
placebo-controlled on our best value a
shin of this was was making use of this
neoadjuvant data set published in 2011
we extracted triple negative portion of
this data set and applied to predict a
our signature to it and we'd see no
difference in in distant relapse-free
survival according to diagnostic arm in
these patients that did not receive the
drug which indicates that the the
biomarker is likely predictive and
hopefully not simply prognostic now at
this point this is typically where
research you know has to end and and
thus this has been turned over for
commercial development but a lot of
times that's where it fails because it's
very difficult to translate one of these
technologies into a meaningful and
accurate and reproducible technology
that can be clinically utilized now
what's different here is that we have
this wonderful tool from nana stream
called pro cigna which is already on the
market in order and allows for for
classification and measurement of gene
expression from ffpe tissues and has
already been validated in breast cancer
in the triple negative cohort because we
feed our biomarker can make use and
actually you know the best use of the
biomarkers we tested was based on the
same set of genes that are assayed by
pro sigma that is the pam 50 genes so we
hopefully had a quick means of
translation to the clinic and that's
because a lot of the work that needs to
be performed in order to make that
translation happen had already happened
for the pro stigma assay but i want to
visit that now just to just so it's
understood the level of effort that it
takes in order to to move one of these
assays into clinical utilization so the
project natal say is already a validated
platform has more than 300 systems
worldwide for testing breast cancer
in producing the risk of relapse score
it was based on a paper in journal
Clinical Oncology in 2009 and the model
captures the heterogeneity of breast
cancer gene expression in producing the
model so in producing the the prognostic
outcome so it's not simply trained
directly on on on the outcome without
knowledge of the underlying biological
heterogeneity and in developing this
assay a number of very in-depth studies
were performed on behalf of nana string
and in collaboration with myself and
other academics in order to ensure
repeatability and accuracy of this assay
the first such experiment set of
experiments were described in this paper
by Nielsen in this RNA precision study
there are graded a hundred assays used
to assess variation so there were a set
of ten samples these were basically one
for each subtype basal her to enrich
luminal a and luminal B I guess two
forms of luminal B here and then this is
there were two examples of each of these
so ten independent samples and for each
of these two independent samples they
were run through different sites and at
different operators at each site
different reagent lots by each operator
and different runs per each reagent so
so four levels of replication here to
produce a very large set of data that we
could use to analyze repeatability and
accuracy at multiple levels what we find
in report in this paper is that the oral
are scores across all these levels of
all these levels of variation were
extraordinarily tight extraordinarily
accurate and very reproducible and you
can see that in the top left by the low
variation RoR scores which is expanded
out into histograms and the rest of
these for each individual sample in the
study so there are only very by a couple
of points for each individual sample
across all these levels of replication
and variance component analysis
indicated the predominant variation
within run and then reagent lot another
experiment that was performed was to
take a larger pool of samples and assay
them at three independent sites with
independent pathologists operators RNA
isolation kit lots and then run in
duplicate and so for each of these we're
seeing on the right the resulting risk
of relapse score relative to the tissue
average on the x-axis so there should be
stacks of points representing each
individual sample and you can see that
within each each kind of vertical stack
of points there's very little very
little variation only a couple of our
award units across these three
completely independent runs of this very
large sample set we also found that in
other studies that some amount of normal
contamination could produce variability
this was initially published by fatty
olu me and melissa tourister back in
2011 and we looked at its effect on R&R
RoR relative to the percent non tumor
tissue more recently in this study in
2014 and find that that the type of in
the type of contamination does play a
role and thus pathologist review is is
necessitated and required prior to
putting these studies through the acid
through these samples through that today
the result of all this work is the pro
signet test which is an amplification
free and automated protocol that can
turn around samples in two to three days
it has 510 K FDA clearance Tennessee
March for FDA tissue ffpe tissue and
produces the reports like you see here
to generate the risk of recurrent scores
this assay we could then leverage
because of all this development we could
then leverage this as much as we can in
order to get the test that we're talking
about now which is this in salida much
sensitivity test to market as fast as we
can and what I've shown you then is that
that a lot of steps are required
characterization verification validation
all these things would be required in
order to take any of the other assays
that might be viable and could be
perfectly accurate biologically but to
make them clinically actionable but
because we have this test in place and
we can we can produce the proper
measures in order to provide sensitivity
measures to in Toledo mod using current
instrumentation a study was designed in
order to test this in a more robust
manner in this randomized double-blinded
phase 3 study called in dear patients
will be screened using mass a discussed
today and those are considered
diagnostic positive will be randomized
to one of three arms a ninja la involute
amide plus paclitaxel arm which will be
compared against a placebo plus packs
attack paclitaxel arm to understand the
improvement in this diagnostic positive
population a third group will also be
assayed which will be the single agent
arm to match the phase 2 trial and this
this particular trial be run worldwide
hope hoping to enroll approximately 2200
or screened 2200 patients to enroll
around 780 and with that I'd just like
to stop and thank all the folks that
were involved in development is
diagnostic first the pan 50
commercialization to pro Cigna and all
the the work that had to be performed in
order to get that done that that would
include the folks at the Huntsman Cancer
Institute like Phil Bernard torsten at
UBC and then of course the our
colleagues at nana string and where I am
and with Chuck Peru as well as others
here at UNC then I'd also like to thank
those that Medivation such as her desh
and aiming Katrina
for helping us push through with this
triple negative study of involute ahmad
as i believe it's going to be very
beneficial to two patients that are
diagnostic positive and thank you all
for listening thank you so much for your
presentation dr. Parker we want to start
our QA segment so here's a reminder as
to how audience members can communicate
with us questions can be submitted view
via the Q&A button at the lower left if
we are unable to get to your questions
due to time constraints dr. Parker will
be answering submitted questions via
email so let's begin with our QA a first
question dr. Parker is how can you be
sure the signature is predictive of
sensitivity and not just simply
prognostic so yeah that's I mean that's
a tough one because it wasn't a
randomized study for this phase two and
so ultimately the only way we could know
if it is truly predictive is to have a
placebo-controlled phase 2 study because
of the the nature of the study being
single arm we only have kind of one side
or one way to look at this data and
that's in those patients that receive
the therapy what we'd like to know is in
a randomized row is this is the
signature also not providing benefit in
those did not receive drug as I showed
you the best estimate we have of that
comes from public data which is the
which is the the study by hats us at all
back in 2011 and that's that they were
treated with a standard chemo
therapeutic regimen and and followed up
so that we could look at disease-free
survival estimates those data were
microarray data so they were a
completely different protocol than or
assay protocol than anything else I
showed today so that has to be taken
into account when evaluating it however
I do feel that that data set is a very
good data set in both representation of
the population as well as the quality of
the assay data that was produced and
thus I'm
I'm confident in those estimates and in
our ability to subtype the samples and
incompetent in the diagnostic crisis I
agnostic positive negative classes that
were assigned and in that study there
was no difference so so we that's our
best that's our best estimate so far
however it will never take the place of
having a true control alarms as part of
the clinical trial thank you for that
one audience member would like to know
will you be able to run this test with
RNA sequencing
so this is this question is yeah it's
interesting because we did develop the
biomarker with RNA sequencing so that
seems very reasonable and a lot of you
know a lot of Institute's now I have RNA
sequencing capability however I hesitate
to recommend it at all because of the
nuances of RNA sequencing I love RNA
sequencing I'm so glad you know it's
been such a wonderful tool for discovery
and and you know made this study
possible by being able to to discover
the biomarker using RNA sequencing it
however there are so many RNA sequencing
protocols out there and and many of them
are you know are not clinically viable
simply because they won't work well on
ffpe tissue and when you Whittle it down
to just those protocols that do they
have just not been they may well have
very good accuracy and repeatability of
course I believe they do that it just
hasn't been shown at the level needed
yet in order to use it as a clinical
tool so while one day it may be possible
right now and the reason we you know
look to nana string to do this is
because you know we believe these data
can help people right now and so we want
an assay that we don't have to wait and
develop Nana staring gave us that
ability by having you know the ability
to run RNA expression estimates from SSP
tissue and having devices in the market
that can do that right now thank you
thank you for that important response we
have some great questions come in but we
only have time for one more an audience
member would like to know does the model
provide any biological insight into the
disease so you know well anything that
so much my short answer is yes but
that's you know there's certainly some
some room for interpretation here
because we haven't done anything
functional yet to show this but
but my thoughts here are that it's
simply the context of this study being
triple negative breast cancer they have
that means they lack estrogen receptor
they lack progesterone receptors they
lack or two yet the model is picking up
on those patients that that of the
triple negative population look like
luminal patients which are typically
er-positive p r+ and sometimes seriously
positive and so my thought is that
androgen receptor positive or engineer
scepter sensitive patients are these
patients where androgen receptor is
somehow taking the place of estrogen
receptor or progesterone receptor and
driving the disease because the
signaling that we see is or at least the
gene expression patterns that we see
look like luminal tumors where typically
estrogen progesterone her two are
driving the defeat here what we see is
the lack of those markers and and those
are the samples that are sensitive to
androgen receptor and so just putting
those things together I feel like the
model what the model is telling us is
the luminal tumors that are that are
showing sensitivity that androgen maybe
driving some subset of triple negative
tumors to really be of the luminal
subtype thank you for that dr. Parker do
you have any final comments you'd like
to share with our inquisitive audience
joy you know just thanks for letting me
present this work if it didn't come
through I'm extraordinarily excited
about it you know it's uh I think for me
this is a lot of people talk about the
promise of genomics and this was one
instantiation of it because in this
instance we take a drug that's been
approved in a completely different
disease and we identify patients which
will using genomics which should be you
know subset of patients in a disease
which the drug is not indicated that
should be sensitive and by doing so take
a drug that has you know a fairly good
safety profile apply it to the right
subset of patients in a different
disease and the result is a doubling of
their overall survival time with a
potentially better quality of life
during that time and so so you know
personally I hope we can just continue
to see the fruits of genomics by
applying it to clinical trial scenarios
like this so far genomics has told us a
lot about about biology and has been
used as a wonderful tool in in basic and
some translational research what we're
seeing year is really the power of it
when we can apply it in the context of
clinical trials and I really hope this
Spurs more use of genomics and true
clinical trials like this one thank you
so much dr. Parker I'd also like to
thank today lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through July 2017 keep an eye
out for an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
to replay and we encourage you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues to me as miss today's live
event thank you for joining us and we
hope to see you next time goodbye
everyone
you